if you see the letters i'm starting a
section b okay
um if you see the letters gtp
it's not because i meant to say http
and i got confused um gtzb stands for
get to the point get to the point
not not not gamer text transfer protocol
or something like that okay
so yeah okay all the different things
that gtt
now what did i mean you have a look at
the section i've highlighted
right and probably most of you have at
least one or two
or ten to fifteen of these okay
in your extended response in your
extended response okay
you you don't have that much space and
you don't have that much time now i know
it was a long exam
okay but often you're sort of your own
worst enemy you know when you're in a
maths exam
and you pick out a method for solving a
question
but it's not a good method it's a slow
method slows you down and then at the
end of the exam you're like man i was in
section e
and i didn't get anything done it's not
because
the exam was too long it's because you
slowed yourself down at the beginning
right so by putting things wrong with it
so commonly
let me go to section b and i'll pick an
example commonly what you'll do is
you'll start
writing your answer um a bit like an
essay
a bit like an essay and essays have well
what are the three parts of an essay
guys
introduction body conclusion right
that's that's the main
way an essay works and if you didn't
have an introduction your
um your marker would say where's the
introduction because you can't just leap
into
here's my text and here's my techniques
and blah blah blah right
but these are not essays okay so for
instance this is just the first one that
jumps to mind
turn to page nine let's have a look at
uh 22
part c i know i'm skipping ahead but
this is just an easy example
okay the question says
as with all feature films iman 3 could
only be produced because there was a
team of hundreds of people
working behind the scenes to construct
and refine the finished product
that made it to cinema screens now i'm
putting that in there to give you a bit
of context
right so that you don't get the actual
question in a vacuum
and i connect it to the real content you
got there so it says describe two kinds
of jobs specifically related to the
production of multimedia components in
iron man 3.
now some of you might actually be
staring at it right now circled on your
page
you might have started off your answer
with one or two sentences even
that says iron man 3
was produced with many jobs specifically
related to the production of multimedia
components
right these jobs include now okay let's
think about that right
you've just wasted 30 seconds writing
that and not only is it
not actually contributing to your answer
or demonstrating any understanding
but what you wrote it's in the question
right so i kind of
a lot of your questions your answers
it's kind of um okay great they've
let me know that i've read the question
yes i'm
really pleased but you're sort of
wasting time okay so that's what gttp
means and some of you are more copious
with making that error than others
the key what i'd get you to write down
in your own thoughts and um response
review feedback is this is this is
extended answer
it's not an essay even the longest
answer is like six marks
it's extended answer you just jump
straight into your answer
don't give an introduction okay start
saying things which i can look at and
say ah this person demonstrates
understanding of this
that the other okay
okay um number two
so the first thing gets straight to the
point number two
please always aim to be specific in your
answers
so a lot of the times i'll say specific
question mark or i'll say it's too vague
right here's what i mean when you answer
a question you need to provide
solutions and details that relate
closely
to the given technology or the given
scenario okay
so your answer needs to specifically
relate ask yourself this question right
could my answer the answer i've given
could it easily relate to some other
situation some other random disconnected
situation
or is it well integrated into this
particular
question right i'll give an example if i
ask you okay give me a disadvantage i
outline the disadvantages
for using this system in this situation
right and you've been given an article
or a situation
right um
you might say as a disadvantage right
you might say computers could break down
which is true computers can break down
right but that answer in itself it could
relate to anything you could say that
for
any sort of it's very general it's very
vague it doesn't demonstrate that you
understand anything about this question
right it's just sort of a canned
response you can just pull it out it's
it's kind of like um uh when someone
sends you a text response
and it's just like um you know okay or
lol
or you know something something
meaningless which is like well you could
have said that for anything right it
doesn't say you're actually listening to
me
it's a bit like the equivalent of when
you're talking to someone and they're
like uh-huh
yeah oh okay
oh yeah now all of those sounds right
they don't demonstrate that you're
listening to someone at all it's just
the sounds that we make when we don't
know what else to say
right so it might be valid but if it
doesn't demonstrate understanding by
being specific
then i can't i can't reward it right
okay number one get to the point number
two be specific number three
okay now please take this
the way that sports players in a team
take feedback from their coach
and they don't perform that well in a
game okay it's not that the coach is
like oh
i'm so angry at you i don't like you
people you disappoint me that kind of
thing right
i'm just trying to help you for next
time so that's why i'm giving you very
specific critical feedback okay
now this is an open book test open book
it was open board right
now that means that the scholarship
multi-choice really should have been
much better
than they were let me just check i've
got it here
our average for multi-choice our average
score out of 20 was
let me pull it up
out of 20 our average score was
12.6 12.6
okay multi-choice they're kinds of the
the questions which are difficult for me
to pose
in a thinking sort of way they tend to
be okay look here's a piece of
information you already know
right like you just have to identify
which is the right one and it's in your
textbook or in your notes
right if you if you've done all of the
class work okay so
there's that no excuses right you need
to know your content better
and uh lastly okay
i think lastly is this my last piece of
general fever i think it is
okay put this in big red writing if
you've got a red pen there okay
in this course in ipt right you can
never
simply say computer
computer the word computer right don't
use it in this course
ever okay here's why every piece of
hardware that you've ever studied right
has some kind of computational power
right otherwise we wouldn't really
study it um it's got inbuilt
microprocessors so everything in a way
is a computer so you can't say this
computer on my wrist or this computer
which is a
mainframe or this computer which is
server or whatever you guys know enough
to be able to distinguish between them
okay and i saw this coming up again and
again and
again people would say computer this
computer that you need to be able to be
specific enough for me to say oh
okay i see you know what kind of a
computer is right
other courses maybe you can get away
with it ipt no you guys know there are
hundreds of different kinds of computers
okay so be specific
are there any other general questions or
any other pointers
um on sort of like acronyms that i've
written which people don't understand
yeah
okay i think my points were get to the
point
quickly um make sure your answers are
hold on specifically related yeah
specifically related to the situation
thirdly because it's an open book test
right and in some ways
uh well no no the the open book
the this test that we're going through
was open book right
no excuse right i don't know how much
did you refer to your books
during the test a lot not much seems
kind of mixed okay
i'll give you a quick example when i get
to it in a minute there's a data flow
diagram
a data flow diagram a data flow diagram
now if you drew an arrow right and it's
like the package goes this way and then
the plane goes this way and then the
people go over there right
they're not data so that's not a data
flow diagram that's like a thing
object item flow diagram that's a
textbook issue right
if you don't that's that's kind of like
a look there's an approval test should
have known
okay so that was my third point okay
okay